[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia high open show
we have
lots going on today um a very exciting
guest somebody
who has nearly i think it's over half a
million subscribers on youtube
somebody who is a very good friend but
before we introduce him i do want to
give you
a really quick news announcement because
this is powered by icon plus so
really quick announcement for you guys
so visit me icon's cover 19 compliant
visitors management app
has surpassed 100 000 users
and is now being used by by excuse me by
a hundred thousand businesses
across the globe so this is really
exciting it includes hospitals
um hilton the comrade hotels all in
south korea so this is very very
exciting it's a really big milestone
for icon especially in such a short
period of time so
back to leia heil pen show very excited
to announce we have
nicholas martin nicholas great to have
you how you doing
i'm doing great lyr thanks for having me
it's nice to catch up
yeah it's good to catch up with you i
don't think we've spoken
in a really long time like a very long
time
yeah i think it was probably like
pre-covered you know the world's changed
so much since then but you know what's
exciting is you know things are
obviously getting better it seems and
you know the crypto market's been
butting up ever since then you know it
kind of came out of this
bear market we were in back in uh you
know early 2019 and
it's a really exciting time with
everything going on at d5 and congrats
as well on the news as you mentioned for
icon
you know i've been following icon since
back in 2017.
yeah i got a pretty interesting one
they're doing some crazy stuff
in south korea just every single week
we're hearing
more and more news coming out about
different partnerships um
with the government and i mean i guess
they're kind of just going straight
ahead with everything that's going on
with covert so it's pretty cool
but we haven't spoken in a while and
since we did chat
you founded a whole new company you
founded something
pretty exciting so tell us about fox
yeah absolutely yeah i appreciate it so
basically what i've been working on
since
i guess pretty much about when we last
spoke was i kind of spotted what was
going on in the decentralized finance
space for a long time it's what i wanted
to see in the crypto industry because i
think finance is really the killer
application
so as ethereum and the decentralized
finance ecosystem continue to grow
we've been about we went about building
a cryptocurrency wallet that abstracted
a lot of the complexities of crypto
and allowed you to plug into all the
different services that you'd want
whether you were wanting to trade or
make swaps in different cryptocurrencies
earn interest on your stable coins or
other crypto assets
and being able to send payments to
family members and friends across the
globe
and that's basically what i went about
building i completely self-funded
the kind of like pre-seed stage to the
company right when it was getting
started
we built out a functioning you know a
minimal bible product got onto the
market
got a lot of people testing it and now
we basically got around
around 11 000 users in this case who are
testing out the application giving it a
go
and giving us a lot of great feedback in
this case around the application
uh so it's been a great journey so far
we're excited to continue seeing it
growing and we're
excited to keep plugging in more
applications and services into the ace
of digit fox
yeah it's really exciting i think you
know it's really cool just to see
people growing in this space creating
new things
innovating especially i think because
when you first sort of showed me this
whole idea
you were sort of saying you know it's
something that i've needed something
that i just don't think is available and
for me i think that's one of the coolest
things about crypto that you actually
have the ability to innovate
you know like things are just moving and
you can move with them basically
yeah exactly i think the the my whole
kind of thesis outlay as you mentioned
is it's building something that
was fixing the pain points that we
struggle with like i mean i constantly
hear people complain in the crypt of
space that you know
oh you know x company doesn't do a good
job or this this kind of industry
leader is is it really doing their part
and it's like well i mean we have the
resources at our disposal we have the
network effect the people who are
willing to trap these maps
let's go out and build it let's bring
the right people in and one thing that i
wanted to make sure i did is that we
brought in a lot of people
who weren't traditionally working in
crypto um like our a lot of our
engineers
uh our designer a lot of team members
who are doing like client success or
doing customer support and creating
content
a lot of them didn't work in crypto
before and over the last few months
they've absorbed all the knowledge they
needed they've been able to build a
really stellar product
we have some of the like leading
industries security standards
where digifox is just like any other
crypto wallet it's not holding your
funds
uh and we plug into again a lot of these
great services providers who do uh you
know do what they do best
comparative to what we would do as a
company so i think in that case it's
it's really been a great journey so far
um we even did an equity crowd funding
so we wanted to try to raise from the
community first before we went on to
venture capitalists and the traditional
guiding mechanism so it's been a lot of
fun
it's been a learning journey as well
yeah it has been and also like major
congrats to you because you've been
surviving during this crazy crazy year
right
yeah it's been a it's been definitely
kind of rough and stuff you know i i was
a separate for me personally like my
girlfriend we were separated for a
couple of months
she was over in europe i was here in the
us and for the company as well you know
we've been all working remote natively
so it's been a it's been an interesting
time i mean i think we're very blessed
because we kind of work in a digital
space so it's familiar to us you know we
can scale it out very well
and of course as people have been
indoors now content and education around
blockchain
has obviously been more in demand than
ever so we'll have to see here um
in this case you know over the long term
how things go but i'm very very excited
to see how it grows yeah it's been a
really crazy year
so i want to jump in and talk about the
markets i want to talk about 2020. so
you
are one of the biggest youtubers out
there you talk a lot about d5 and
uni swap and everything that's been
going on so i want to
start essentially by asking your thought
on the markets right so there's a lot of
red across the board um
you know we talk about bitcoin sort of
leading the alts right
so if bitcoin fails we say everything
else is going to fail if bitcoin runs
eth will
run so what is going on with bitcoin we
had the halving everybody sort of
expected
um i would guess by the end of 2020 for
bitcoin to
have done looks like better because i
personally am still very bullish and i
think it's doing great
staying above 10k but i just kind of
want your thoughts do you
is this right did you expect it to be
higher at this point
what do you think yeah one thing that
i've emphasized throughout the channel
and i actually just did a video on it
yesterday
is to actually look out of all things at
gold for inspiration for how bitcoin's
price is going to move
so gold for example right for many years
when central banks were printing
excessive amounts of money we had all
the fundamental case for gold going up
in value
uh the problem was is that there really
wasn't an actual catalyst in this case
to to drive gold up as an asset there
wasn't something that
actually caused that shift because
equity markets were where money had to
flow to
there was clear trust in the asset class
and because of that people weren't
looking for alternatives like gold to
hedge against
you know massive currency depreciation
or traditional institutions
so when we finally uh back in like kind
of like late 2018 early 2019
golden actually breaking out above its
line of resistance
and what it did is it actually did
something that we see in a lot of assets
where it comes down in price
afterwards and make support on that
previous line of resistance very
simple but long-term technical analysis
and then after that we had about it if i
remember correctly if you were 66 weeks
for gold to get from when it made
support on that line of resistance
up to uh breaking the all-time highs and
something that i want to emphasize to
people
that was around a 50-55 move but the
thing is is that bitcoin in order from
this point to get to its you know
all-time highs
uh it's you know around 20k in this case
you're gonna have an even bigger move
than 55 that's going to be required and
along with that as well
you know the time frame in this case
could be you know up to 66 weeks it
could be shorter
so what i always tell people is like you
know take the most conservative estimate
here like the most practical
you know you know kind of low
expectation kind of outcome
you believe bitcoin is going to go to
20k in that case
i would say that at a maximum it could
take up to 66 weeks it could be shorter
it could be something like 33 weeks i
think somewhere in that range
is a very fair assessment and that is
going to lead us into a time frame
you know if we're even doing that
shorter term time from the 33 weeks
where at the earliest quarter one of
2021 is when we're going to be breaking
back to those all-time highs
so it doesn't surprise me in the
slightest uh that we're around this
range
that we're out right now around 10 300 2
500 for bitcoin and the last thing i
would say as well to keep in mind with
just bitcoin as an asset is a lot of
people talk about kind of a four year
cycle
i personally disagree with this pretty
extensively because if you look at
blx which is like the longest index for
bitcoin
um you can actually see that from bottom
to top for each cycle we add about
a year's worth of price action it's
usually 11 to 13 months extra with each
cycle
so that's going to leave us with a new
all-time high peak
most likely in november of 2022 almost
stepping into 2023.
you say early 2021 right when we talk
about giving it x
amount of weeks you know you said 30
weeks six weeks whatever it is
but do you think it's more it's a matter
of sort of seeing
an actual run at that point because
obviously that's sort of what we're not
really seeing at the moment or are you
talking actual highs or is that
2022 you see it yeah yeah so that that
basically that projection of 33
to 66 weeks that's when we're expecting
to break to new
like break above 20k so we're now
starting to charter into new
all-time high territory my uh november
target that's uh there are too many
numbers but this one would be like
that that's the new kind of 20k peak for
uh
for bitcoin which you know i'm basically
estimating it's going to be somewhere in
the ballpark between
and again i know this is a very wide
range but 100 to 200k
and the reason i leave such a big room
of leeway in that case is because no one
knows
the kind of momentum that we're going to
see here for bitcoin we've seen
you know i remember in the last cycle i
thought oh 10k easily the target for
bitcoin
and i basically started to take some
profits
in that case and then luckily i held
some still because it just kept climbing
and climbing and climbing to 20k
so it was uh it's fascinating to see how
kind of the wave of both retail and
institutional capital
can completely change the dynamic for
price and our current expectations so
those are some kind of estimates that i
have here but above all i just i
emphasize to people have your
expectations as low as possible
if you're a hodler or you're kind of
focused on the long term and let it be
that you get surprised and things
actually happen in a quicker fashion
um in the long run but yeah i think
you're right leia as you said earlier
bitcoin is an asset
it's still performing great it's still
one of the best performing assets over
the last year year and a half
so i think in this case i feel quite
comfortable being positioned in crypto
the way that i am
but it's really interesting because you
know on twitter you know that's where
you and i first connected
um a lot of people there's a lot of
dislike towards bitcoin
and people are often sort of saying you
know when when you sort of say
something positive about bitcoin there's
a lot of um repercussions i would say a
lot of people sort of turn around and
sort of say oh that's so ridiculous you
know
it's old technology but you know you're
still here saying
highs of hundreds thousands whatever
you know give it two years so what why
are there such
different opinions like what is going
wrong here why can't we just sort of
agree
um you know that bitcoin has value this
is what its value is
you know math code and so on right
limited supply this is sort of just like
science
maths rather than like opinion do you
know what i mean like why can't we agree
on these things
yeah absolutely i i think it's it's two
dichotomies here where
you kind of have two different camps
that have formed i think there's been a
very big disparity as someone who's been
building on ethereum
i've seen it firsthand uh the kind of
sense of maximalism between
both camps on either side and kind of an
isolation but
the ironic thing is like i i constantly
look at it and to me it's like
it's us shooting ourselves in the foot
to put it simple um
you know for example yeah i know exactly
why are we doing it
i think more than anything people are
constantly afraid of either side
removing the need for one another
and i really don't think that's the case
um so i can give you like a great
example right
i've been building on ethereum so i
think that ethereum no doubt is the
leader in like decent trust finance in
the sense of like financial applications
earning interest
being able to make decentralized swaps
it's clear right now like it's it's the
platform where i've interacted with the
most tools just not even trying to look
from a bias just
from what i've experienced yeah no i'm
with you yeah yeah but in the case of
bitcoin
i think bitcoin's monetary schedule it's
it's monetary policy
is much more favorable than ethereum uh
there are some proposals for ethereum
to um actually burn some of its supply
to become actually like deflationary
but these are all just kind of
theoretical at this point um i think
bitcoin even if
ethereum you know completely mimicked
bitcoin's monetary policy
i don't think it will ever reach the
network scale of bitcoin um as a kind of
safe haven
or uh safe independent asset or
something that could be compared
to a digital gold it takes time to build
brand recognition like that
and i think bitcoin being the the first
cryptocurrency being as consistent as it
has been
it will probably hold that title for a
very long period of time if not
forever in the cryptic space uh so i
think in that case that's why i mean
you know you can you can be all about d5
like i am
you know crazy about ethereum as an
asset but i also really love bitcoin in
the sense that i think that you know
there's no asset that
is guaranteed to get to that trillion
dollar market cap more than bitcoin
um and yeah sure maybe you know yeah
yeah i mean it's like i mean i think
that's a great
i hope overall i mean i've seen it as a
good perspective because i mean i'm an
investor at the end of the day
you know i don't i don't want to i don't
want to let my biases get in the way of
what's going to happen in that case or
where i put my positions in the market
yeah you can't be emotional about it 100
you have to look at the facts and you
have to sort of say okay well i'm going
to choose bitcoin because of x y and z
but i think you make two huge points
there which really get me
i made it the other day got yelled at
right but i stand by it
household names matter right
so you know you talk you one of the main
okay look like let's talk about
bitcoin's value
um from a math and code perspective
let's put that aside just for a second
i definitely agree with you in that you
know it is the first
it has that recognition and whether or
not we sort of think
bitcoin will be the global currency or
will be the current what you know
whatever it is
i still think it's the currency which
will bring about mass adoption
in that it will just in that marketing
works right
like it's so far ahead on so many other
on than many of the other coins now if
you look at ethereum
for example this is like my second
question to you because somebody
actually explained
to me which i thought was pretty nice
they said that bitcoin
would be digital gold and ethereum is
like amazon
and do you know what i'm gonna give a
shout out to the guy that said that so
it's the ceo of old coinbase
everyone yeah sure he's great yeah he's
amazing
he's brilliant um so shash said to me
that
ethereum is basically like amazon
and to me i was just like that's
brilliant like that makes sense
um and it already has that recognition
as well because i guess there are
a lot of different protocols that are
trying to do the same thing but they're
not going to really
get there just because they don't have
that that same recognition right
yeah absolutely it's it's a network
effect i mean the reason amazon is so
dominant
and that example that shashpop is it's a
good point like
the reason why amazon is so dominant is
because it has a network to pretty much
everything you need it it
started off obviously shipping off books
that did one thing uh and now
basically you can get everything from
amazon content you can
actually get some services from amazon
they're experimenting in every avenue
and this is why amazon became such a
dominant
almost kind of like you know kind of
tech monopoly in the sense to be able to
service all these different things
um but to point you back really i think
it's so true
like overall like um you know in the
broader sense of the crypto space
i don't think uh if i were to give
people the option like you know hey do
you want bitcoin do you want ether
i think most people are still going to
take bitcoin and it's simply because of
brand recognition and network effect um
now ether
you could say the exact same thing about
ether compared to those other protocols
you mentioned
that they might even have way better
they might have way better tech you know
maybe as you mentioned icon um you could
have
like my chain yes so much
yeah yeah you can have all these
different networks and the problem is
is that they they don't have a means
right now
at least we haven't seen it i know
there's some that are working towards
providing better developer resources
there's no way you're going to be able
to capture ethereum's kind of network of
developers
um at this current moment we i do this i
just haven't seen anything like that
unless you make the transition extremely
simple um so yeah
i think in that case that's that's a
very clear point there lately and above
all
for cryptocurrency assets um you know
the one thing is like
for digifox for example we don't try to
toss
ethereum or bitcoin or litecoin at
people right away
the first thing we kind of service
ourselves as is a
new age finance app and the the first
thing that a user is going to see is a
way to deposit from their bank
into stable coins we want it to be
familiar we want them to have dollar
backed stable coins in this case so it
feels exactly familiar it's like you're
moving
ten thousand dollars from your bank to
ten thousand dollars in digifox
and now then we can say hey you want to
earn a higher interest rate rates of
interest on your savings you can do that
through our providers
you want to be able to buy
cryptocurrencies you can do it through
our on-ramp providers or our
decentralized exchanges
and we just kind of make it seamless
with whatever user needs in that case
um but i think that that's the way we
have to go with crypto we can't
um sit by and say that it's perfect
right now but at the same time
uh giving them that option where you you
get them in the door first to a system
where they have every option so you
don't need to depend
on their commercial bank giving them the
opportunity to buy bitcoin or buy a
crypto in any capacity they can do it
now because it's from their own
interface
under their control i love it and
that's sort of just you know when you
say relying on like commercial banks it
sort of just throws me back to what was
it like two months ago when
um banks got the green light to sort of
hold your crypto i hated
that so much like it kind of just
really got me at my core i was just like
but we're here to get away from the
banks you know
it it just kind of threw me but anyway i
want to ask you actually
um i want to talk about the us
presidential election because it's
coming up
and elections always affect the markets
whether it's traditional markets
whatever it is you know bitcoin really
isn't
a non-correlated asset um you know we've
seen how it's correlated so
first question for you is how do you
think i guess the whole virus the whole
pandemic has affected
the price of markets and bitcoin and
then secondly
um how do you think the presidential
election
will affect it yeah i think it's a good
question so on the virus in this case i
think it had its largest effect when
there was absolute peak fear and
uncertainty
so i can remember like when i was back
and it was in early march i was visiting
to talk to a few investors for digifox
at the time
in new york city and bear in mind i was
in new york city
during like the peak set of fear and you
could start to like walk through the
streets and you would hear people just
like
kind of like on the phone talking about
it it was like you could tell through
the day got worse and worse
and i was i would simultaneously
watching the market because this was
when we had
i think it was black black thursday by
tuesday whenever we had a crazy sell-off
in the market
um where ethereum had its worst day
bitcoin had second worst day in history
uh so for me it was like this is this is
like oh my god this is
absolutely terrifying well luckily since
then bitcoin's actually rebounded since
central banks have printed a ton of
money
i think with the uh prolonging of the
economic effects of the virus i don't
like to look at it as a
positive investment thesis but i do
believe that if central banks keep
printing
um it is just going to push it's not so
much that there's excess amounts of
liquidity because
originally that could just go into to
stocks in this case
but what you see now is you're getting a
lot of money that's in the bond markets
traditionally that's usually kind of
hedging on risk
um that's now actually getting pushed
out of the market a lot of that value is
going to be pushed out because
interest rates are going to turn
negative in the us very soon they've
already done so in the uk
uh with the bank of england and along
with that as well
you also have the excessive printing of
money which is penalizing people from
the small yield that they were already
getting in the first place
so you have negative yields you have
excess of printing you're going to
probably be moving some of that capital
outside of bonds and it has to go into a
lot of different niche markets i think
actually shaman hit on this recently um
shimon who's previously worked at
facebook and it's now one of the major
hedge fund managers
that a lot of people follow he put up
this point where we should be focusing
on a lot of alternative or niche markets
and crypto is one of those and i think
that that's exactly what you've seen
where bitcoin's gone from
you know the rock bottom at 3k when
everyone was panicking
up to around 10 to 11 000 and we're
seeing micro strategy
acquiring bitcoin you're seeing
grayscale getting peak institutional
demand for their
uh etns that they have for
cryptocurrency assets um i think these
are the kind of early warning signs of
it but
the thing too that people need to
understand is that this stuff takes you
know a year to two years to really show
real ramifications it takes time for
people to make these moves
um and overall i think you know above
all there's there's not any other asset
class that i want to be positioned in
um and during this time of code i think
that there's a lot of great room for for
crypto to continue being seen as a hedge
especially if it gets above 20k um
now you brought this with a question
about the elections um
you know interestingly enough i don't
really know how to feel at lake because
like you know
i've come it was funny when i was in
europe over the last few months i kind
of was disconnected from everything but
when i've come back i've seen that it's
still the same kind of division now
we're getting towards the election
season where it's a bigger topic
and i really don't think there's going
to be too much of an impact on crypto in
this case and the reason why is that
as much as it is correlated um i think
that the
the bigger dynamics here for bitcoin is
i don't see that um
any results of the election leading
towards a big buy
side activity or sell side activity of
crypto which would lead price one way or
the other
um maybe you'll see a maybe a hundred
three hundred dollar movement bitcoin
one way or the other you know who knows
what what side is going to lead that to
happen
uh but i think in that case like overall
it's kind of up in the air there's been
there's usually it tends to be that when
there's very fear-based macro events
uh like when we had and i ran for
example back it was like a year ago
when we had the the potential world war
iii that everyone was talking about i
was so
ridiculous i'm sorry yeah
yes sorry that was ridiculous no it was
pretty crazy and it was like everyone
was panicking and you can start to see
bitcoin bumped up a bit because
people were like hey you know it's a
head you know but i'm curious to hear
like from your take leah like from this
two topics
do you have like uh do you have a
feeling that it's gonna swing one way or
the other from like continuation of the
virus or the presidency or
what would it yeah let's do it so i mean
so i don't think so bitcoin
is not like okay people talk about it
being like this non-correlated asset i
absolutely don't think that's the case i
definitely think
um what happens geopolitically affects
the price of bitcoin right
as you mentioned with the whole iran
thing we saw a little bit of a spike
um you know with the hong kong protest i
think what was it when it was at its
peak
nearly two years ago we saw a spike or a
year and a half ago or something
um my view on the whole covenant 19
thing is pretty simple right so
back in march when things were extremely
unknown there's a lot of uncertainty it
makes absolute sense that bitcoin would
drop down to 4k for me
there's no shock there but i think it's
so powerful that it comes back
up and it stays above 10k like i a lot
of people complain
about this but for me this is really
really powerful
i mean we've already seen for me how the
dollar is how the pound is the euro
none of them are doing particularly
great right the pound is just getting
weaker and weaker
um the uk don't actually have any
negative interest rates just yet but
they are considering it
right i don't think yeah no it's okay
yeah i think that they're considering it
so
this is concerning so for me like you
said you know the worse
it gets from an economic perspective um
with the uk with uh the usa
we will look to defl deflationary assets
like bitcoin i
100 agree as for the election coming up
i really don't think it's going to have
that much of an effect i just don't
um everyone's like oh you know markets
go crazy during these times and they do
but you know if you're talking about
okay uh 300
rally you know up or down to me that's
not an effect
because that's what we're that's just
normal you know bitcoin
every day in crypto yeah right so like
when bitcoin is stable
that's weird so if bitcoin goes you know
up by by whatever like 300
to me it's nothing i i don't see this as
an effect so honestly i don't think
there's gonna be
um i don't see that being much of an
effect at all but
i want to move on a little bit actually
and chat to you a bit about d5
because d5 has been crazy over um this
last year
but my main question is do you think d5
is going to be
something a bit like icos of 2017
whereby
it's this big thing people made a lot of
money people lost a lot of money
it was fun it was cute whatever um or do
you actually think this is just the
beginning
um because realistically this is still
the experimental stage
so we're talking a lot about nfts at the
moment which we'll get to
but in terms of d5 is this just the
beginning or
do you think we kind of we kind of hit
its peak yeah
i think it is just the beginning leia
and that's both a good and bad thing
um you know with any kind of wave of
innovation you have
a ton of companies it's almost kind of a
wave of speculation at the end of the
day
because the vast majority of it is not
going to be very
innovative or it's not going to be
something that sticks around long term
like we saw with ics i think
the failure rate will be a lot less than
icos because i see is where just
anything goes on a blockchain whereas in
this case we actually have a little bit
more of a specific focus of finance and
i think
with um you know when you take finance
versus all categories that try to be
tossed at blockchains
you're gonna get a much higher success
rate because blockchains do a really
good job of keeping
low low level data for very important
data right so being able to keep the uh
the record of transactions allowing you
to interact in a permissionless way
this all goes into the root of finance
but at the same time
you know as someone who's been building
in d5 for the last few years and i've
used
i've been supporting kyber network since
2017 i've been
following you know ave or you know ethan
back in the day and
compound and all these protocols and
many of them are already integrated
into digifox i've got to tell you later
it leaves such a stain on my heart
personally seeing the space grow in such
a fundamental way
and then seeing the craze around guild
farming uh seeing the craze
around ridiculous interest rates in
yield farming and also
uh just the kind of instant switch to
nfts and not really like trying to
trying to be kind of rational about it i
think that to me
is not what defy is not that those
things can't be defined it's not that
there can't be people who seek out
yields that are higher than usual maybe
a little bit more risky
and it's not that nfts can't be um you
know a great thing but i don't think
people are assuming they're assessing
the risks of these systems overall
when you lend out to compound for
example
when you lend your assets on compound
it's very realistic yields that are way
better than what you get at a bank on
your stable coins and other digital
assets
and at the same time you're actually
heavily protected in this case because
it's over collateralized on the
borrowing side
um whereas when you put your money in
something like uh like wi-fi for example
they have like uh
that's been the big thing wiring in this
case if you put it into a urine vault in
this case
uh where you're earning like 80 90 i
don't know what the numbers are now but
it used to be like 80 90
on top of your ethereum the way that it
would work yeah
it's a very seventy percent or something
something crazy that's insane
yeah and basically the way you would
make that yield is
you're putting your ether into a maker
contract so a lot of people don't know
that they're actually taking out a loan
so if if ethereum goes down 50 they lose
everything
so say goodbye to the yield and say
goodbye to your principle and then along
with that as well
the way that they're making this yield
is they're farming governance tokens
that are
kind of a short term they're not going
to be as hyped as they are right now
and along with that as well the yield
will dry up there so when the yield
starts drying up
you're going to have this really bad
dilemma where a lot of people
you know are probably selling youth in
this case getting out of that yield in
that case
of the wiring vault and you're going to
start to have a really negative effect
on ethereum where all this kind of
inflow came in originally
but along with that if it gets worse
enough it goes below 50 percent from
where a lot of those contracts are the
the vaults were open
it's going to be a massive margin call
event and that's something that again i
don't think people really realize in
that case or assess as a risk
for these protocols you make an
interesting point though
that it sort of puts a stain on your
heart in terms of
you know there being something there um
pretty decent when it comes to d5 but
things like yield farming things with
these insanely high interest rates which
are of course highly risky naturally
um i guess sort of like take the
attention perhaps away from d5 what it
can do what it's supposed to do
um and i guess it sort of makes it into
something that
i don't know it kind of loses it some
some form of credibility especially when
you start sort of hearing all these
supermarket type tokens coming out and
do you know what i mean and i think and
i think especially i know i know
twitter just happens to be the heart of
crypto really because it's where we can
all connect but i know there's a lot of
people who aren't in crypto but they see
what goes on and they're just sort of
like
this can't be right this can't make
sense so
do you feel that things like yield far
may have sort of taken
credibility or not so much credibility
but have sort of like um
put maybe a potential bad kind of name
overcast on d5 is that what you're sort
of saying yeah
i wouldn't say that it's it's like
killing defy or anything but i will say
leia like i i think you probably agree
with me
trying to tell someone to get into yam
token
and it's like it's like what are we
talking about here like
what kind of image does this like the
thing i hate is that like if we were
just saying we're just experimenting
having fun and speculating
i would say hey at least everyone's
being honest at that point but people
are saying we're building better finance
we're
we're revolutionizing the financial
system we're becoming the same
traditional financial system
that you know caused the 2008 recession
that caused previous recessions when we
take these kind of speculative gambles
and push code that's unaudited on chain
this is completely off of what's
traditional in the blockchain space in
the open source community
and and quite frankly like i can just
tell you like i personally have no
you know urgency to integrate any of
these things into digifox because
for me i want to build something that's
familiar for everyday people if we
really want to reach that you know
100 million or billion users across the
world who need crypto right
now you're not going to want to toss yam
finance
or sushi and all these things that
people what you want to give them is a
way to say hey
young money in a bank you want to take
it over to this platform and start
earning interest or
buy get exposure to digital assets maybe
even earn digital assets and not have to
spend any money
um i think things like that are really
what's going to bring a lot of people
into this space and it is a bit sad to
play that like
i mean it just seems like the simpler
and the more stupid you keep it
like the more successful and like you
know in the short term that it is and
people just go randomly speculate on it
oh straight up like i absolutely agree
with you on that i think
we over complicate things hugely and um
i gotta be
super honest with you um and our
audience as well like i think
our biggest problem with mass adoption
is ourselves like people
look like i also appreciate that like
you know things need to scale
um 110 percent need to be able to scale
you know
we're waiting for ethereum 2.0 and so on
but i think
over complicating something is just the
the worst way
to do this right to get new people into
the space and i think
um and also coming out with her crazy
crazy
risk reward situations like we're
talking about yield farming and so on
is going to be one of the most
off-putting things um but i also want to
chat to you then about
uni swap because i know you've done some
videos on that what are your thoughts
did you give it a go and did you get
your 400 unit
yes i did so i i was uh you know i think
in total i claimed three wallets in this
case so i i'd happen to trade between my
digifox wallet and a few metamask
wallets so i was very happy
in that case i was very blessed but
overall um you know
you know i think here's the thing about
uni i think uni proved a very good
example of how you can do
a token distribution right by giving 15
percent of the supply of course maybe
i'm a bit biased because i received some
but
i think in this case giving tokens to
people who supported your technology
before the issuance of the token
i think is a fantastic way to give back
to the community
and outside of that as well you know i
think that the
idea of building governance you know
overall having a governance token is
probably the most speculative element i
really don't know if these
you know the hype around governance is
really going to play out in the long run
but i can see at least that there is
some utility with having the governance
power on top of uniswap which
is one of the most it's not only the
most valuable d5 project by total value
locked up
but along with that as well is where
people make major swaps in this case for
for cryptocurrencies i've been using
uniswap as well
it's by far the best decks that i've
worked with in the sense of liquidity
and the sense of a seamless experience
and that's why we integrated it into
digifox that's natively
how people can make swaps within the app
um so overall
i think it's fantastic the uni token is
definitely an example in the right
direction versus the
you know if you just think about like
take it back to 2017 like a couple years
back
where the state standard was the team
gets 50 and investors get 50
of the token or like you know basically
89 between those two groups and then
you know maybe 10 percent for community
development or this or that
now we're starting to see unit swap is
putting up massive allocations of its
tokens more than 50
in this case directly for the community
and i think that that's a very good step
in the right direction
and i i can tell you we had a lot of
users who made swaps who happily claimed
their tokens and it was just
so nice to see how happy people are uh
getting to have some stake in that
system early on
yeah i think i think you're totally
right you make a great point um you know
because a lot of the time
when an ic you know when there's an ico
whatever at the end of the day
you know of course you can read up on
the project but you still are taking a
gamble
um it's actually such a pleasure to see
a company sort of
the other way around like you said and
reward the people that gave it a go
believed in them you know whatever it is
um
so how do you think uni is gonna fair
then because like let's be honest there
are what like 6 000 different cryptos
at this point including tokens and
whatever and
every single project has a token or a
coin or whatever
and some of them just have them for the
sake of it to keep you on their
ecosystem
some of them have really crappy use
cases i'm not even gonna lie some of
them
i just much rather like get get bitcoin
as cash back or i'd rather get
whatever it is you know so how do you
think
uni will actually do do do you even need
it
yeah yeah yeah i i think again like it's
you know this idea of decentralized
governance or taos
or you know decentralized autonomous
organizations it is still highly
speculative at this point the idea of a
dow
sounds like many things in crypto great
on on paper
but you know a dow can only be as good
just like any government as the people
who make it up
in this case who make up that
governmental system you can have the
best governmental structure it doesn't
matter
it's always going to come down to the
people who make the calls in this case
that's why we have a government
um so in this case i'm still highly
speculative of where
you know comp token or uni token is
going to do
in the sense of like actual fundamental
utility i have no doubt
i would agree with you 100 on that i
don't think there's any clear
uh you know defined utility outside of
maybe what they've mentioned
in the kind of white paper or what they
mentioned on their website with the
launch of the token
but i will say this from an investor in
trading
perspective i'm basically i have not
sold my uni tokens yet for all three
wallets that i was able to claim
and i'm definitely looking to to add
probably more because
i know uniswap in this case is a great
protocol
it works i know hayden and team like you
know i've been following them for a
while
they've done a phenomenal job building
something valuable their token you know
metrics are much better than that of a
lot of other d5 protocols
and at the end of the day as a trader i
know this if the market is excited about
the underlying protocol utilizing it
and the token has some tied to it it's
going to probably do well
um you know again i think above all like
this whole d5 space i've been i kind of
shouting it through the roof
since 2019 with oracles and enterprise
blockchain and d5
but finally we're starting to see it
materialize and i think this is just the
beginning of the broader cryptocycle so
if you just want like a trading
investment perspective again
never financial advice but just for me
personally like i think that this space
is going to continue to climb
and i think maybe over time what we will
finally is like it'll
it'll figure itself out we'll figure out
what the utility is for this maybe it's
not just a governance token maybe
it allows certain utility on the
platform maybe you can pay
uh one thing i've thought about is using
like a token like that to be able to pay
for fees
on the native network in that case or
like liquidity provider fees and stuff
like that so
i mean we'll see what happens in the
long run but i'm very excited to see how
people will continue to experiment on
top of what's already been launched
and speaking of screaming things um
through the roof
the last topic i wanted to talk to you
about was nfts because
nfts like you said it's sort of been
this overnight kind of change this
overnight kind of hype over it
i've heard for a long time that it's
coming um my quick
opinion on this would be that i
definitely think um there's there's
definitely a market for
it it's definitely going to become a
thing if you want to put it that way and
the main reason is somebody asked me and
they sort of
and i sort of said well the same way
everything has moved online whether it
be
dating or socializing or working you
know it's just moved online i see
no reason why things like collectibles
and so on and so on not just
in gaming but in the wider world we'll
move online
um whether it be like you know you've
got the same way like socializing you
have twitter and
people sort of speak through twitter we
communicate through twitter
um i think we will have collectibles and
objects that are ours and we have like
this virtual room for them
and so on and so on so not just gaming
but i see it going bigger but
firstly what is your opinion on that and
also
well yes it can become there could be a
market for it and obviously is a market
for it but do you think it will actually
um be a craze like we saw with defy
i don't think it's gonna you know i
think nfts if i
if i were to say anything like they're
kind of like a fragment
of d5 like a digital asset collectible i
think that
you know we've kind of seen it we've
seen it blend into the broader term of
d5 d5 so wide reaching its lending
applications it's trading applications
um and derivatives and all types of
financial services insurance
so in this case i'd say nfps are another
category in there um so i don't think
it'll be ever as big as d5
but i will say as as you mentioned the
the potential i see ford as a market in
this case is that if you can
build up a big enough network effect
where
major companies and brands are producing
you know and in-game digital assets like
you mentioned as one
but also different types of collectibles
if you start to see artists and people
take a liking to it
in that case there will be a market if
they if the people
you know for example you know the people
the reason people collect baseball cards
is because you know they're they're the
players that they enjoy
if you know uh the you know major sports
leagues in this case start creating
cards
and start creating collectibles in these
formats people are gonna probably take
them
uh just like they would you know a paper
card i mean really if you think about it
you know i have a i have a baseball card
in my hand right
what gives that value right it's a piece
of paper with a printing on it
well it's that it's a actual certified
collectible and that's where i think
again nfts can have some value is just
being able to authenticate ownership
um you know over that specific
collectible sure you can make the
argument oh i can find photos of it
online well yeah i can find a photo of
my baseball card as well online or photo
of
you know the the actual baseball in that
case but it doesn't matter like
in this case as you mentioned we've
digitized everything at this point
um and i i don't i think personally for
me i don't get it too much like i'm not
one to really buy collectibles too much
but i know that there's a market of
people out there you know that many
people don't get crypto
but i'm a crazy you know nut bag for for
loving crypto and i think i think we
both are we
we're crypto fanatics at the end of the
day and we don't make sense to the world
yeah for sure i mean you know just talk
about like that that latter bit in terms
of like cards for me it's just such a
no-brainer
um because even even you know like now
we see kids using
um oh gosh well someone's calling me how
strange let me just decline that
that's very strange came through on my
laptop um yeah even
even as we see kids using ipads now
right
and that is and a lot of you may agree
with that i disagree with it but sort of
like toys
entertaining children is now done in a
digital way
so if we sort of say okay well kids play
with cards i don't do you have top
trumps in
in the us or is that yeah i don't know
you do
okay it's not just a british thing great
so you know as a kid we were always
playing with top trump cards
and a part of me is like well you know i
guess kids don't have access to
electronic devices at such a young age
but they do
um so things like that it's like for me
it's just an obvious kind of evolution a
natural evolution
moving things like that online i mean i
used to play with brat dolls and barbies
actually didn't play barbies but i
played with brat dolls
and for me that will just go online as
well
like i i don't see yeah i i could
definitely see it i mean
yeah go i'm sorry yeah i i don't yes
sorry i think sorry there's been a
connection drop yeah
i agree i think there's there's nothing
that's going to stop it in this case
like if there's enough companies doing
it
i think that the biggest thing we have
to look for and this is something we've
we've considered at digifox we're not
100 certain on it but like
having a real interface and a market
where you can actually like manage these
assets i know openc
does this um where there's actually a
secondary marketplace where you can sell
your digital assets for a certain amount
of crypto it's usually dominated
um but yeah i think for us you know we
would love to you know possibly support
that in that case we just wanna
for us i think it's a matter of waiting
for that killer kind of like nfts
made similar
to like what crypto kitties were in 2017
where there's actually a big enough
network effect
where there's a market for it you could
sell your collectibles
i think when you can make a liquid
market around collectibles and get
enough users into one network
that's going to be the game changer in
that case that's it's really going to
scale out this market to something that
people are really interested in
because right now it's a it's a bit
spontaneous you know
you see like a piece of art for example
that someone puts up and they charge
1080 for it
and you got to sit there and think like
you know like hey what what does the
market think about this do they think
this is worth ten dollars has someone
bought this and paid that price already
or like
what is it like and the thing is you
don't have that data or information to
see
has it gone up over time so i can know
if i want to speculate on it or if i
think it's overvalued
i think that's what's going to make this
like an actual liquid market that people
want to trade
and get involved in i want to get your
thoughts i'm not going to put the
comment up because they have a bit of a
weird name but
somebody just wrote in the comments they
say but it's physicality
um which gives it protection against
duplication digital images don't have
that inherent protection i absolutely
disagree
right because the whole idea is that
it's decentralized it's on the
blockchain it sort of stopped
you know it protects it from again let's
say bitcoin or crypto for example it
protects it from the whole double
spending problem like surely that's not
even
a concern right yeah i i would say to
that remark in that case uh physical
objects in this case do have a
duplication issue uh if i for example
create a duplicate or fake version of a
baseball card or even some kind of
physical
object that happens in a lot of cases in
a case where people sell
like counterfeit goods things of that
sort same goes in the sense of
collectibles and you can get yes they're
are certification
programs and stuff i mean for example my
family members collected baseball cards
for their entire life and
actually just recently sold some of them
um but i would say in the sense of a
a verifiable nft what you get out of
this is yes could you see like an image
online yes
could you for example just have an
in-game item and not have it be an nft
on a blockchain that's yes very true
um but the nice thing about an nft is it
does give you a certificate
on chain that actually states that you
own an asset and i say that is probably
the most
valuable aspect of it again for me i'm
maybe not the best to speak on it
because i'm not majorly into
collectibles
but i will say that that ability to say
under my address
that nicholas merton owns this specific
asset
i mean that that's a major thing i mean
it's not only big for bitcoin and crypto
assets to know that like
you know a bank isn't rehypothecating or
fractionally reserving my funds out
but along with that as well same goes
for the nfts if i want to hold it for
the long term you think it's going to be
valuable
i want to certify that i have ownership
over it and when i exchange it to
someone they now have ownership over it
and i think just lastly i think like the
cool thing about nfcs is that it's so
much more than just collectibles right
like i think even at the moment you have
domains which are nfts
um i think i've got one yeah i do have
one i don't know i think i don't know i
said i think i do have one so
you know that's really cool so that can
go up that can also go up in price
whether i'd want to sell that in however
many years i don't know
um but i think that's super cool so
nicholas i'm going to give you i'm going
to make you full screen i'm going to
figure out how to do that
let's do this now i'm full screen you're
full screen cool i want your last words
like something
and something beautiful tell us yeah
well let
first off thank you for having me and i
would say above all the the thing that i
would say to people in this space right
now uh where the market is right now
with all the kind of excitement going on
the thing i would say above all is to to
realize that we are very early on in the
cycle
if you're here right now in the crypto
space i've been in the space since like
2016 2017
i can tell you all that this is very
early on in the cycle uh we've got a lot
of more a lot more innovation coming in
the sense of decentralized finance it's
going to start becoming a lot more
practical
the best thing you can do is just cut
out the noise and focus on the long-term
vision
as we talked about earlier with bitcoin
i really believe that we're at a point
now where we can start to prepare in the
next few quarters to break above those
all-time highs and
continue the rally and i think bitcoin
will be the best mainstream
asset in the sense of performance
against gold against silver
traditional stocks bonds so if you're in
crypto you're in the right place and i
think that d5 is only going to further
expand upon that growth
and give us all types of new ways to
interact with our financial future so
i'm very excited about that and above
all if you guys are looking for
something to tap into d5 digifox is a
portal to that
but uh outside of that as well
and yeah above all i mean it's so great
to be here and just get to chat with you
as always it's it's definitely had been
too long since we talked so
i'm glad we made the time to do it yeah
it's been great thank you so much
guys thank you so much for tuning in and
thank you also to icon plus for kindly
empowering this
guys i'm going to say goodbye and we'll
see you next week ending the broadcast
bye bye